pourquoi il n'ya pas de partis
politiques autochtones au canada
oui bienvenue à part à l'automne si ces
milices à mort l'une du puits cette
semaine je vais essayer de répondre à la
question de sa mie au mieux de mes
connaissances puis je pense que c'est
une question est quand même assez larges
contrats pas un parti politique
autochtone au canada même au québec
ou est ce qu'elle est la problématique
c'est qu'on va parler du système
canadien soit fédérale provinciale donc
c'est le système colonialiste pour les
communautés autochtones
il faut pas oublier que c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas de parti politique
autochtone qu'on n'a pas de la politique
autochtone qu'on n'a pas des politiciens
ou des gens qui vont défendre le
politique chez les premières nations
je pense à l'apn qui l'assemblée des
premières nations où la pn tu es
l'assemblée des premières nations du
québec et du labrador ce qui je pourrai
voir est l'équivalent fédéral et
provincial de nos partis politiques mais
qui ne représentent pas des partis
politiques traditionnels comme on
pourrait le décrire
je sais qu'il ya des partis politiques
autochtones qui veulent se démarré mais
il ya un enjeu qui est très difficile
c'est de faire un parti politique pour
un seul groupe de la société imaginez si
je faisais le parti politique des hommes
blancs du québec vous pouvez comprendre
que ray un tollé parce qu'on sent qu'il
n'est pas une représentativité de
l'ensemble du groupe
un parti politique doit défendre
l'ensemble du groupe qu'ils soient
autochtones ou qu'ils soient non
autochtone c'est un nouveau citoyen est
là cette responsabilité là en tant que
parti et en tant que politiciens parce
que sinon on exclut des gens donc ce que
je vois qui est beaucoup plus sain comme
comme approche est d'avoir des comités
citoyens au sein même du parti politique
qui vont défendre des enjeux qui vont
expliquer les enjeux des droits docteur
qui sont très différents aussi des
droits des citoyens non autochtone et
par la branche vont pouvoir aider à
s'assurer que les enjeux autochtones
soient compris soit défendu mais ne
s'oppose au centre même du parti
politique
donc ce serait un peu plus difficile de
faire un parti on voit des gens que ce
serait un succès parce que qui irait
voter pour un parti qui parle seulement
pour
petit groupe je pense qu'on voit la
problématique ça a été une problématique
dans l'histoire en tant que tel d'avoir
des groupes expliqué exclu mais la
parole des autres citoyens
alors ça me tue comprend que je pense
qu'il faut qu'on continue ses
discussions là mais ce serait très
difficile de faire des parties parce que
ça ferait des conversations très fermée
sur elle même et ça nous permettrait pas
de trouver la solution tout en
respectant le droit des communautés
autochtones à travers le canada
alors j'espère y avoir bien répondu
j'espère que vous allez partager ses
vidéos et nous envoyer des questions
je souhaite une belle semaine